Now with our dentist example,
we wrote 3 dentists out of 5 dentists
to describe the ratio of dentists
that prefer a certain toothpaste.
But in math, our units, which in this
case we're referring to dentists,
they behave a bit like numbers actually.
And so what that means is when I have
dentists over dentists like this,
I can actually simplify by
just crossing out the common,
we can think of it as a factor.
This means that 3 dentists out of
5 dentists is the same as 3/5.
That is our ratio here, and
it's just a pure number again.
No units involved at all.
We'll see why this is useful in a bit,
but
first let's do a little
bit of practicing.
Let's look at the first ratio
from our previous question.
8 out of 10 cats prefer Whiskas.
Can you write this is a ratio?
Enter your answer in this box, and
keep in mind what we did here to go from
3 out of 5 dentists to just 3 over 5.